the future of flight shouldn't be things
with propellers and turbines and should
be more like what you see in Star Trek
with a kind of blue glow and something
that suddenly glides through the air
when I got an appointment at University
I thought well now I've got the
opportunity to explore this and started
looking for physics that enabled that to
happen this sort of mechanism I found
that works was a ionizing air and then
using electric fields to accelerate the
air what we achieved was was the first
ever sustained flight of an airplane
that is propelled by electro aerodynamic
propulsion and that's also by many
definitions the first ever solid States
like meaning no moving parts
well the idea is is kind of it dates
back until at least the 1920s where a
eccentric inventor at the time started
experimenting with high high voltage
electrodes and thought here discovered
anti-gravity which of course was not the
case but that set some of the initial
groundwork on mechanisms for creating
what's called an ionic wind in the
atmosphere by having high-voltage
electrodes ionizing air and then
accelerating the ionized air so what we
did for this design is to try and stick
to something that looks somewhat like a
conventional aircraft but under the wing
rather than conventional engines it has
a series of electrodes and those consist
of a an array of very thin wires at the
front and then an array of Aero foils at
the back now those thin wires at the
front are set at a very high voltage
plus 20,000 volts and that constitutes
the source of ions this is ionized
nitrogen from the atmosphere now the the
air fault of the back there set in minus
20,000 volts and so that creates an
electric field so the ions go from the
positive to the negative colliding all
the way with neutral air molecules and
creating this wind that goes behind the
plane and that's essentially how it
flies the flight was about 60 meters
long something like 10 seconds so quite
short
it was constrained by the size of the
Jim that we found to fly it in lacking
infinite money in time and just wanting
to do things as quickly as possible that
was what was on hand and so we just
asked the facilities manager if they
would let us use the Jim they force us
to create a very long and detailed
safety management plan but then we're
able to go ahead many attempts failed
because the various things going wrong
like structural failures the power
electronics frying itself so there are
many many first days but the first day
that it actually works wasn't a
sustained flight it was about 50% power
so it was a power glide until that
occurred we still didn't know 100%
whether this was really achievable but
after that point we knew that we were
then within touching distance or
successful flights and the first
sustained flights
followed quite soon after which were
which were pretty exciting it's probably
the first solid-state flight of a
heavier-than-air vehicle and I think
that is has the potential to be a step
that is very interesting of course we
don't yet know whether it will
practically useful and why the years and
obviously I hope it will be and have an
expectation there are a number of
applications there definitely some
limits so one of one of the limits is
the breakdown voltage of air and that
varies as a function of altitude and
we've worked out theoretically what the
limits are to the thrust density which
is the amount of thrust force per unit
area that's producible now what that
suggests is that in the near term it
will be easier to create smaller
vehicles like drones for example I think
the near-term advantage is probably a
noise especially if you think bets
perhaps in ten years we might have urban
areas that are filled with drones doing
things like monitoring traffic
monitoring air pollution or many other
services were yet to imagine and drones
today are quite noisy and irritating now
we wouldn't want our urban environments
to be polluted by all this noise so
developing a way of propelling drones
that silent or near silent would be
advantageous in that context
in many ways it's much easier to make
progress now than it than it was in the
past I mean if you look at this
wonderful aircraft behind us which was
the first ever transatlantic flight
about 1919 I mean people were risking
their lives to make that kind of
progress today we're not risking our
lives we're able to test things using
your remote control without having to
have pilots and board test vehicles that
means the vehicles can be much smaller
which enables us to build them and test
them with less resources in terms of how
this fits in I don't know whether you'll
see large aircraft carrying people
anytime soon that obviously I'll be very
excited if that was the case
[Music]
[Music]